I don't know if in general as a society
we're getting grosser or if the
Internet's just bringing it to the
surface but I just think in general
there's a movement towards perversion
that feels new to me the first thing
that made me think this was a couple
months ago I went on a date with a guy
then we went on a second date on the
second date he asked me if I could
squirt let's talk about it look first of
all I do not squirt just so you know I
am NOT a squirter I am NOT squirting I
am NOT a squirting lady I don't know if
I'm just dehydrated if I need more
Gatorade in my life I'm not squirting
okay
I mean if you want I will compromise and
I will pee on you I'd rather not but if
that's your thing I'm sure I could
fashion some pee I have to turn on the
faucet I'm not into it
here's that this is new this is a new
thing five years ago I never heard about
squirting okay five years ago I feel
like the gross taboo thing every one of
their girl to do was anal it was all
about anal right now anals just like you
just have to do that now it's not even
weird anymore it's just like on the menu
it's not just for birthdays anymore it's
happening which I do not think that's
okay I think we need to make it weird
again I think we need to make it taboo
again this is how I know anal sex has
gone mainstream I have a girlfriend she
has a daughter who's 16 years old
she was to a Catholic school and she
said her girlfriends in the Catholic
school at 16 years old are now having
anal sex instead of regular sex so that
they don't technically lose their
virginity right have you heard that my
thing is if you're having anal sex
at 16 years old to stay right with God I
have news for you
there is no God get a new religion
because your God fucking hates you